Instancing is the idea that a single geometric set of triangles can be reused
again and again. For example, for a lamp, you might have a single piece of
geometry for a bulb fixture. If you want three bulb fixtures, you then set up
transforms for where the objects go but reuse the same set of triangles for each
one. In three.js a mesh of triangles is called its geometry. Though you often
hear it called no objects mesh, a mesh in three.js, is a type of object. This is
easy enough to do in three.js. If the geometry doesn't change, just reuse it.
Here's a simple example. I create the geometry for a cylinder, and then reuse it
again and again for each mesh object that I make. Note that an object is made
from some geometry and a material. This means I could've given each cylinder a
different material while we're using the same geometry. Say, I have a car model
with 4 tires. The question to you is, which of these are valid reasons for using
instancing for tires? It allows an individual tire to be shown as our of air and
flat. It reduces the number of transforms needed. It can use less memory. It
allows some tires to be drawn with less geometry than others.